I'm lyin Shonda editor of Elle global
online as it turns out i'm in South
paulo brazil and tom friedman the author
of hot flat and crowded actually is in
our studio at Yale so I'm going to ask
stump from questions about his book tomm
welcome to Yale nine is great to be back
here I with Yale global thank you Tom
since your last trip to our studios you
have produced another book hot flat and
crowded why we need a green revolution
and how it can renew America it's the
most timely book and what struck me is
though that you wrote all this flat as a
cool isn't analysis of how globalization
has flattened and from the planet your
current book is a critical it's a really
very strong emotional appeal to the
world to save itself now what has menu
so emotional well you know dying it just
is part of an evolution it's not like
people haven't been emotional on this
subject before I have long before you
know whether you know going back to
Silent Spring so I hardly discovered
climate change or biodiversity loss I
certainly didn't discover energy poverty
I did discover petrol dictatorship I
didn't discover energy natural resource
supply and demand well I've done in this
book I hope is maybe brought them all
together and tried to show people how
they're all one problem and have one
solution I think that's that's my value
add and to do it in a way that it's
passionate because you can't be a parent
today and not be passionate about the
world that were we're creating and
abusing at the same time yeah i think
what word also struck me
book is that you have your earlier book
world is flat was somewhat celebratory
of globalization that how it can remove
poverty and shrunk the world but in this
current book your mood is the
distinctive blooming in saying that I
quote you the impact of globalization is
mr. sizing to cause what is being called
the world's sixth great mass text
extinction now perhaps you can explain
to our viewers how this mass extinction
is happening because of climate change
well the extinction fear the extreme
care about it now the extinction phase
that were in right now it's a loss of
biodiversity plant and animal species is
happening for a number of reasons one
has to do with climate change but that's
actually not the most important the most
important is simply development the fact
that we're plowing up more and more of
the world's tropical forests despoiling
more and more of the world's great
fisheries are polluting more and more of
the world's great rivers and lakes and
the combination of that with then
climate change is putting enormous
stress on the world's incredible bounty
of plant and animal biodiversity and we
are now in the phase of a real
biodiversity mass extinction we're
according to conservation international
losing one new species every 20 minutes
species lost today is a thousand times
the norm of you know fifty years ago
well if anything today were a thousand
times the norm if it were rainfall a
thousand times the norm or spread of
hiv/aids a thousand times it's a norm we
would sit up and that would be
front-page news but we don't talk about
this and when we lose these incredible
plant and animal species we we don't
only lose parts of nature and its
natural beauty that inspire poets and
our
and and make life worth living but at
the same time we lose that incredible
knowledge and wisdom of nature and
creating some of these things and we
have no idea what cures natural cures
for disease are being lost in this
extinction phase yet your description of
what you saw in the Amazon rainforest
was really very very moving and this is
in fact one of the great many of these
books that you have a very vivid
description of what's happening with art
now you have coined a new phrase energy
climate era now what differentiates this
from what we had before and when does
actually begins
well basically what I'm arguing is that
the energy sources that powered the
Industrial Revolution we thought were
going to be permanently inexhaustible
inexpensive and benign what we have
discovered as we've entered what I call
the energy climate here around the time
of the millennium is that these energy
sources that have powered our growth
since 1750 since the Industrial
Revolution oil coal gas aren't
exhaustible expensive and toxic toxic
for the climate toxic for the air we
breathe toxic geopolitically because of
the kinds of regimes they empower and so
to me the boundary line between the
previous era and the energy climate here
or between the say the common era and
the energy climate here is this crossing
of a line where they're very fuels that
power our growth go from inexpensive
inexhaustible in benign too expensive
exhaustible and toxic and I think that
is a fundamental shift and as a truly
heuristic device I like to call this new
era the energy climate Europe because I
think issues related to energy its price
availability and impact on the world and
the climate are really going to shape
more politics than any other factors as
we move deeper into the 21st century
yeah Tom you have also said in your book
that it is perhaps better for America to
create green jobs rather than demon the
disappearance of blue-collar jobs to
China India Nels life now what would it
take to create these green jobs well you
know some very actually simple and
relatively low-cost initiatives 9 let's
start with green collar jobs will you
change the building codes in cities and
make it really economically advantageous
to put up solar panels on your roof
because the local utility will have to
buy that solar power from you or you
change the code round insulation how
home has to be insulated at any given
time at what level and you'll create a
huge demand for home insulators and
solar panel installers those are
blue-collar jobs that i would call green
collar jobs and i think you're going to
see more and more of those kind of jobs
building a wind turbine installing a
wind turbine that's a that's a big
manufacturing formerly blue collar now
green collar job so that's really what
I'm focusing on at that end at the high
end of course as we more and more need
for the scientists who can design those
solar panels and drive their progress
forward so they become more and more
efficient there's going to be a huge
demand for middle kind of white collar
jobs that will also be green collar jobs
to come in and help design or implement
energy efficiency in your own home so
all those I think will fall into the
category of green collar jobs
to be the last the rescue package that
the Congress passed had actually
restored the tax credit for renewable
energy industry now that of course the
positive thing but the crisis it seems
to me is going to make it more difficult
for people to argue for using alternate
energy what do you think is likely to
happen well as a David Rothkopf energy
consultants as you know will this
financial crisis be the end of green or
could green possibly be the end of the
financial crisis I think that's a very
very important question right now I'm
extremely worried I'm worried that the
falling price of oil will reduce
consumer demand for energy efficient
products and better mileage cars and at
the same time will reduce the
willingness of venture capitalists to
take risks on more expensive renewable
fuel knowing that it's going to be
harder for them to compete in a
marketplace of two dollar gallon
gasoline as opposed to four dollar
gallon gasoline yeah that that problem
actually is perhaps a little less clear
in places like China you have been to
China since you wrote the book you have
been there many times before what did
you find in your last trip to China
about what the Chinese are planning to
do about alternative energy source well
I think China is really ambivalent nigh
on the one hand their growth needs are
so overwhelming and coal is so
overwhelmingly cheap and available to
China both through domestic and foreign
sources that they're going to continue
building coal-fired power plants at the
same time they understand for their own
needs and for in response to the world's
pressure they're going to have to move
in time to a cleaner
energy system right now nine their
Chinese are on the fence they're sitting
there kind of waiting for us they're
basically what if the Americans don't
move why should we move and we're saying
well if the Chinese don't move we won't
move and we have to break out of that we
America I think have to take the lead i
think if we take the lead china will
follow but I don't think China will lead
this because the inertia for China which
is to just keep sort of digging up coal
and burning it for electricity is going
to be just enormous yeah I think that's
similar attitudes i skip to see in India
to I think Indians are also heavily
reliant on calls and they're saying that
if you give us for clean coal technology
fine but otherwise we simply have to
produce electricity and we are going to
go call so that the danger we have as we
are see the increasing challenge for
climate change and what do you think the
Indians that could do or should go well
you know what I say the young Chinese
and in some ways could apply the young
Indians although they are a per capita
basis produce much lower co2 emissions
is that what I say to young Chinese is
every time I come to China young Chinese
say to me mr. Friedman you got to grow
dirty for a hundred and fifty years now
it's our turn and to which I say I know
how you feel I understand how you feel
we ate the entree we ate the desert we
ate the hors d'oeuvre and then we came
to you and said here's some teeth let's
split the bill well that's not on people
think that's really really unfair and I
understand that and so what I say to
young Chinese is that you're absolutely
right we got to grow dirty for 150 years
now it's your turn take your time take
your time grow as dirty as you want
because I think when a country my
country just needs five years to invent
all the clean power technologies you
China are going to eat before you choke
to death and we're going to come over
here and we're going to sell them all to
you and we're and we're going to clean
your clock we're going to clean your
clock
in the next great global industry and
that's when I see them adjusting the
headsets from the interpreter saying
what what did he just say and so my
point simply did young Chinese is I
understand you think it's unfair that
you should now not be able to burn coal
if we did for 200 years I understand
that but you got two choices one is you
have to understand when we started
burning coal we didn't know it had the
climate effects that it was having
basically and number two and you do know
China today but number two this is going
to be the great in the next gate next
great global industry what I call et
energy technology all the clean power
technologies to substitute for coal and
oil and some country in the world is
going to lead and dominate that industry
I want it to be the United States I
think we get there first if we have a
price signal China will want it to be
China I want to get there first yeah
that's a very good point now he also
have written me a book about the
consumer volcano erupting in societies
which had their son human demand
suppressed for many years and so how do
you tell these people who want to now I
want to enjoy the what the Western world
has enjoyed for so long as the knowledge
that this world kind of consumption he
is going to make life even much more
difficult and dangerous in terms of
climate change see I don't think I don't
think you can tell them not and I think
what you can do is put everything we
have into the inventing into inventing
the clean alternatives and taking the
lead and then selling them in India and
China or manufacturing them there so we
get down to the CH India price the price
at which they could scale in China and
India our job is to pay the big front
upfront cost because frankly we've put
the most into the atmosphere the most
co2 and we have the most resources or we
did before the financial meltdown to
start inventing the alternatives we have
to we have to make the upfront cost and
they have to provide the manufacturing
plant forms to get those upfront costs
down
so these start to scale quickly in India
China yeah so I think the one message
that is very strong in your book is that
here is an opportunity for the United
States to reclaim its leadership in this
area which is going to be determining
event on determining technology for for
the pit of death how do you think that
the coming election and the new
president would give the analysis an
opportunity to really make a clean break
with the past and perhaps even reinstall
the solar panel sutures removed
ceremonially by ronald reagan from the
White House well it's an important
question I think the next president can
and not only can must lead the et
revolution because you know ngayon in a
world that's a that's hot flat and
crowded one thing I know for sure is
that et energy technology is going to be
the next great global industry I know
that as surely as I'm sitting here in
this interview with you what I don't
know is who's going to lead that
industry is it going to be India is
going to be China's going to be a Japan
this is going to be America is going to
Russia South America I don't know that
my argument is that the country that
leads this et industry must be the
United States of America why because if
is Jeff Immelt of GE says if you want to
be big you've got to be big in big
things if you want to be big you have to
be big in big things if we want to be a
big power then we have to be big and the
biggest thing and that is energy
technology ET and the country that owns
ET is going to have the most i think
national security economic security
ecological security healthy population
competitive industries and global
respect that country must be the united
states of america otherwise our children
will not enjoy our standard of living
come again this budget to have you
address to do to yell and thank you very
much it's a treat to be back here with
yell global